déployables n'importe où en 40 minutes
maximum et ultra légères c'est la petite
révolution de la start up here captifs
basée à trappes et crée en 2017
elle conçoit une chambre blanche sous
forme de tentes basé sur la technologie
des voile de kitesurf une idée venue
avec la pandémie crise sanitaire était
en fait un accélérateur pour nous parce
que le monde du médical c'était un monde
qu'on voulait pas trop aborder compte
tenu des certifications qu'il y avait à
faire c'est quelque chose qui est long
et coûteux
cette tante reprend une de nos
structures qui est gonflé blé on vient
suspendre la partie fini les salles
blanches
à travers cette structure gonflable et
on vient mettre en dépression ou en
sueur patients grâce à une partie à
jouer avec toute la ventilation qui
permet de stériliser entre guillemets la
salle pour rendre stérile cette tante et
l'adapter à l'accueil de passion
qu'ovide air captifs s'est appuyé sur
l'expertisé du groupe aura nos situé à
saint quentin en yvelines et sur sa
technologie d'atmosphère contrôler une
innovation conçue en huit jours par les
deux entreprises leur atmosphère
contrôlée c'est que ça permet en fait de
de démontrer que l'air présent dans la
chambre est vraiment contrôler c'est à
dire que dans le cadre du du virus par
exemple du copine et bien là on a pu
démontrer au cours des essais on
arrivait à filtrer 99 % des particules
et donc 99 % des particules qui sont
dans le qui sont rejetés de l'extérieur
de l'intérieur de la chambre vers
l'extérieur sont filtrés depuis son
implantation à travers captifs n'a cessé
de se développer mais la start-up
rencontre un problème de taille elle
n'arrive pas à recruter a des
difficultés parce que tout simplement ce
sont des métiers où il n'ya pas de
formation donc les métiers de la soudure
haute fréquence et la partie couture
couture métier que qui s'est un peu
perdu en france et en plus on fait de la
couture type voilerie c'est pas de la
couture pour les vêtements donc c'est ça
rajoute une difficulté l'entreprise
forme donc elle même ses employés entre
trois et six mois sont nécessaires
actuellement air captifs compte 23
collaborateurs
elle souhaite recruter entre 30 et 35
personnes en 2021
objectif répondre à l'augmentation de
son activité